yeah thank you so much Betsy this is my
best friend so I don't know how you will
how you will trust what she says the
friend would obviously say that thank
you so much for having me here I wanted
to come here but earlier some years ago
but unfortunately I couldn't but today
it came true and I'm here at Yale and
I'm really honor than very glad to be
here and very pleased to be here my my
speech will focus mainly on some of the
problems we face in Ethiopia and how we
try to address them and I hope not only
they are common in Ethiopia but I hope
they also represents many of the
challenge that we face in our continent
so but in order to make it a soft maybe
or smooth start I would prefer to start
it to start by saying something about
how we started you know business or
partnership with yell and I will quote
what President Clinton said when he was
awarded i think in 2005 in his speech i
would read it because it's a direct
quote we only go into places where the
government asks us and we work with them
to develop their program it's their plan
not ours this this is really incredible
this is one of the areas i will be
speaking about that so i started from
what president
and said then I will tell you how it all
started and what President Clinton makes
sense even on the ground you know IRA
Magaziner it was I think senior adviser
to the president when he was president
and he came to Ethiopia in 2006 and the
first thing he said was exactly what the
president said by the way this speech I
found it elsewhere nobody gave me but
now you know he can google anything
anyway so I got it after worldís by the
way not before I met IRA but IRA said
exactly the same thing i Ramona's Enid
when we met and he asked me I think he
came with Joe passion is assistant and
he asked me what support we need from
them what our priorities are and he said
we would help you whatever you want to
do it's yours it's not ours if you want
us to work with you we come they were
not still in then if you don't want us
we don't come so tell us your priorities
let's discuss about them and we can
design ways of helping you based on your
wish and that was incredible then after
we have discussed with IRA on the major
areas of collaboration then ed edd what
would came ed now is the CEO of the chai
Clinton Foundation he came and exactly
the same thing and Edwards job was to
start the job base it on our agreement
with IRA but it was exactly same same
thing and I was really surprised after
we started working based on our
agreement President Clinton came and he
had a speech in the African Union and he
said exactly the same thing so that's
when I knew I think
this is a value that this Clinton
Foundation really shares because all
staff are saying exactly the same thing
this is really a very good value and the
value that we really want as
beneficiaries you know many countries in
the developing world lit bit in our
continent Africa Asia Latin America or
Europe countries who are less developed
one to be held won't on what they do
want to really own their future then
starts from ownership of what they do
what they want but also recognition by
their partners the same way I mean the
ownership issue then after we have
started anyway with Clinton Foundation
the major area that we ask them to
support as was hospital for my hope my
colleagues here told you a number of
times about our successful partnership
on hospital for easier then Clinton
Foundation brought ear limbers into the
picture to help us with we you know the
developing a nail design new model for
hospital reform in each area by the way
before we asked at Clinton Foundation
and yell came we asked many partners if
they would help us in designing new
model systems to reform our hospitals
because our people were complaining of
course still complaining but there are
still many challenges about the services
we give the quality of services we give
in our hospitals and we identified that
after listening to our people who need
the services change we asked many
partners to help us in designing new
models standards to improve the quality
of services of our hospitals that was
the wish of our people that was the wish
of the government but the response from
partners was not positive and that was
not surprising because many partners
prefer to be involved in
some people call it sexy programs could
be HIV or malaria or TB something that
really shows impact immediately if you
invest on systems even before you see
the change it takes time so they prefer
to be involved in something that could
be visible from the start and that's why
we had difficulties convincing our
partners to accept that system issue
system issues are really i can say
neglected in many ways so that makes it
different it was our priority and many
were not willing to support that but i
think an institution which has a value
of supporting base it on the country's
needs has accepted it and brought
another partner who really believes
exactly the same thing then after we
started interacting with young it was
again the same value of course President
Clinton was educated here I know maybe
he got the value from here but aha so
our interaction with the other gain was
exactly the same base it on our wish our
need we say of course our contact is
betsy professor bradley we say this is
what we want this is how we want to do
it please help us on this way and say
you get it no problem because your wish
is our wish that's what they say and
that's really incredible and I think
that helped us in really making this
partnership successful you know owning
your business it doesn't mean that you
don't listen to others you listen to
recommendations you know the
recommendations they give if it makes
sense to you of course if it's really in
line with what you want to achieve if
you really convince it but if not you
should still be supported base it on
what
you need you know to achieve and how we
want to achieve it so that's exactly the
value that we have seen also when
partnering with year after Clinton
Foundation introduced us with University
and when I say successful as you know or
may know the hospital reform menorahs
finalized it and we call it blueprints
I'm years ago we implemented it and
there is a second DVD revision second
edition now revised it manual that
incorporates both the original blueprint
and BP are so better shape of course we
need to do continuous improvement and we
can improve it on regular basis and base
it on that many hospitals have really
changed the way they work and they are
making significant improvements in terms
of the quality of services they provide
and what our people were wishing is
coming now changing of course they're
just encouraging results start I'm not
saying we have done really a lot but
there are encouraging signs and
encouraging results that are happening
because of the introduction of the new
design so that's one success and not
only that after we have started working
on the on the design new design for our
hospitals we have discussed with ZL on
starting a new masters program on
hospital and healthcare administration
mha and we have agreed on that and by
the way the first byte graduated two
weeks ago 25 people graduated and in
ethiopian away we will have the first
professional CEOs who have old masters
on hospital and healthcare registration
and we're starting the same course in
addis ababa university that's why dr.
getting that is here with us and
we want to train as many professionals I
mean mha graduates as possible in order
to lead or manage our hospitals
professionally so on what I said really
is a clear understanding or a clear
example an example if you like of what
country ownership is by the way that's
one of the points I want to speak today
and that's why I started with that but
country ownership as you know is defined
by some you know in a different way and
I will give you some examples but I have
already told you the example of our
partnership with chai and yell and you
will say for yourself which one is the
best meaning in terms of country
ownership this I took it from someone
called Willem Buiter he was working in
the Eastern Europe World Bank unit and
from his research he found out that
there are three different views of
country ownership specialist regard to
plan country has designed country has
significant involvement this is second
opinion the service activities were
informed they see so involvement in
design I mean the country itself designs
it then the second is the country is
sickening significantly involved in the
design and the third is the author it is
were informed then in the implementation
i will tell you another other three
views that really relate to this one the
country implements the program the
country plays a significant role in
implementation this is the nuts second
one in number three authorities of the
country
are kept informed so this is also
country ownership I'm focusing my speech
on this because it has a very important
element in the success of programs or in
the success of whatever a country wants
to achieve because from the example I
gave you we wanted a hospital reform
because our people wanted that base it
on that we gotta support and its
successful now and it's even going from
strength to strength and with ownership
as you can see there is clear commitment
and that commitment can make things
happen not only make things happen
meaning getting results but at the same
time you can start you can sustain also
what you have started so it has a
serious implication and from the three
that you have I have red bay on the plan
and on the implementation I think it has
to be the plan has to be honored by the
country design of course may need
assistance during the process and the
country has to be ready to implement it
also when I days when I say this as i
said earlier it doesn't mean that the
country doesn't listen it listens and i
will talk about best practices letter
and should even actively search for best
practices and incorporate it into its
plan and identify best practices and
incorporate it when it implements base
it on the plan so it should be willing
to embark into continuous improvement
and needs to really listen every now and
then but the ownership and akiva kelly
should be the country's ownership and to
do this the country should be ready to
claim that and say the
is my responsibility and this is my
vision this is how I want to get there
and help me base it on this wish and our
partners should also be ready to accept
that and support still understanding
that during the engagement many things
could change still by should be by
empowering the country in question so
that's the greatest value you have and
that's why I want to thank yell for this
I want to tell clinton foundation for
this because that means a lot to us that
means a lot to developing countries who
want to have a say in what they are
doing because it's when you have a say
in what you're doing that you can commit
to it because you own it because it's
yours then it's when you commit to it
you can bring results and when you bring
results that's it the outcome definitely
will be having impact on the things you
want to do and so the first is just to
tell you how it started and how it's
related to country ownership and also
what the roles of these two great
institutions was and I would like by the
way to thank Betsy for all her support
and of course representing young that I
am saying yell and yell because she is
the product of hell and I can see
through her how Yale is really
repositioned in terms of the things I I
said and we want you to help us continue
in this direction then with regard to i
think i was informed about one question
that of course it will be related to
country ownership as well one question
about how we used
piff our money or global fund money in
strengthening the health system and its
related to ownership and that's why I'm
starting with this one just wanted to
include it in my in my in what I am
saying as I said if you want to own your
own business it should start from
planning you should really own the
vision you should own your plan and in
Ethiopia what our government did was it
put a vision of 20 years this is five
years ago for Ethiopia to join the
middle income countries in 20 years this
was five years ago so it's in 15 years
from now and that's the past dip target
and then the health sector development
program is within that and in the health
sector development program as well base
it on the countrywide plan we have
targets set and owned by the government
itself then what happens is in that HS
DP for instance we have five priorities
HIV AIDS TB malaria maternal child
health these are the priorities in
Africa I don't think there is any
country whose priorities are not this
file and it's not a coincidence they
also are the same MDG goals then after
identifying our priorities in that
health sector development program we
identified the vehicles to with which we
can achieve better results in the five
areas and these are I don't know if you
heard about the health extension program
but the hell's extension program our
flagship that's a community based
intervention then expansion of health
centers that's also as part of the
primary health care and of course the
hospitals which which I told you which
mainly focus on improving their quality
of services but we put primary and
square at the center of the program
because the five could be addressed
using the primary health care approach
so we have identified that
and we set targets how many hellas
posters do we build keep them how you
know then I'm the number of hellas
professionals we need and health centers
also how many do we have how many do we
need in order to you know cover the
whole country and what other needs do we
have related to that so we have
identified that then the subcategory was
after identifying the three vehicles the
system issues what system issues do we
need to address now which ones do we
strengthen and which ones do we need to
change totally and we identified those
areas and information hellas management
information system was one for mass
t'kul finance supply system was another
one health care financing which covers
at his insurance was a third one and
human resource development was another
system issue and harmonization and
alignment based on particle aeration was
the fifth one and other system issues so
we have our priorities we know that
vehicules and we know how to we have for
the priorities we have targets that's
based on MDG goals on some of them even
more ambitious on that then we have the
vehicles that's ridiculous but the main
focus being the primary health care and
we have the system issues which I have
outlined the five and more actually then
we have this meaning we want where we we
would like to be in terms of this fire
you know the three areas the priorities
the vehicles that will take a third and
the system issues we do to strengthen
the vehicles so we have a vision a
government vision middle income and to
reach there all sectors have developed
their plan and the health sector being
one of them developed its plan a very
aggressive on and the [ __ ] the
government's three principles in the
preparation of the plan was it has to be
as fast as possible it has to be as big
as possible and
you should keep the bottom line quality
so high speed big volume and acceptable
quality of course within the development
stats that we have so we developed that
plan and when we negotiated then wins
PEPFAR or Global Fund it was easy
because we we know what our targets are
and we know how to achieve them then we
say for instance if I tell you about
their vehicles okay we are building
15,000 hellas posters and we would I
keep them and we will try and help the
extension workers you help us on this
then health center same thing we want to
build 3200 health centers of course we
have 600 2600 will be built in the next
five years we need money to build us I
keep them and we need health officers
nurses and so on to stuff this holy
centers to start working and about the
hospitals which yell and Clinton
covering we identified that we need this
and we need this kind of support this is
what we want to achieve then the
information system pharmacol finance the
hell is insurance all the system issues
exactly we want this and this is how we
want to achieve it and we need your
support on this so one thing that I
found really fascinating is if you know
what you want even a funding which is
vertically raised can be used for
something that can cover your own
interests also like I think this guy is
from Mexico I forgot its name but about
vertically raising money can be spent
horizontally or diagonally which is true
it can be spent but you have to make
your case and what I said was
fascinating was people were saying oh
this is a fairy's emergency fund I don't
think you will convince them to really
use this money for her system
strengthening don't even try it why why
not we try it at least we ask if it's
not possible that is
possible to say it will not be possible
without even trying it doesn't make any
sense what do we west by asking what do
we lose by asking so let's ask we asked
and I don't know how you were amazed by
the Global Fund but even with PEPFAR
there is funding already are located for
the system strengthening and also for
building health centers keeping them
everything not very different from
Global Fund why because we started
negotiating base it on our plan the plan
that we own apply that we won't why
chief and they said okay we can do this
then another day okay and whisper far we
have a forum and monthly that I chair
representing the government and the
ambassador of the United States in the
country chairs and he comes with his
team I come with my team and then we
meet on regular basis and discuss this
is what we want you help us this way or
but this is emergency no no but we can
do it this way for instance I wouldn't
give you an example we need to expand a
RT services here we need to give a rvs
two people living with HIV and in order
to do that to expand the services you
need institutions if you don't have
institutions you cannot do it then
that's how we try to justify it for
instance you want to do pmtct are you
going to do it under a tree if the
health centers are really not expanded
well you can't you need a facility so
that hell is institution you needed to
do ARB treatment and pmtct can also be
used to do basic obstetric and
comprehensive care so that's how the
vertically raised money is addressing
the purpose the money was sent for but
at the same time is covering additional
services saving women's lives and the
thing that really made this happen was
knowing what you want and knowing how
you want to get there and negotiating
and negotiating understanding their
perspective knowing what they can
knowing what they can't being in their
position also trying to understand them
and when needed even helping them when
they cannot do it understanding them but
at least to the maximum use what's
possible so it needs a kind of you know
relationship and continuous engagement
to make that happen so we were committed
to continuous dialogue continuous
negotiation and to make use of the any
justifications that we can have to use
the funding diagonally or horizontally
but at the same time understanding them
to understand their side and they try to
understand our side too so it's like
saying okay we want to achieve the same
goal you know saving lives so if the
goal is the same then it's not very
difficult for people to see from each
other's angle so I see from their angle
and when they cannot do it I even
sympathize with them say oh this is they
can't do it so let's maybe try some
something else but it worked it worked
so I think we have by the way continue
that forum and the new ambassador
ambassador booth also it's committed to
that and our government is committed to
that too you know continuous dialogue
now I think with the Global Health
Initiative it's the same direction that
we were asking for that Global Health
Initiative is
suggesting now under Obama
administration that was what we were
asking for so the dialogue and
negotiation will be easier now because
there is a formal recognition by the
administration that you know we should
approach it in an integrated fashion
integrated Hurley's approach so that was
what we were asking for and that's what
what's coming now and we were not
surprised by the way when we heard it
appear was part of the eight countries
for GHI plus because that was what we
were asking for and that was what we
were pushing for and how we implemented
and we use PEPFAR funding to strengthen
the health system we used it to build
health centers we're using it to build
our HMIS our pharmaceutical finance
supply system our humanish horses
training even generic you know and there
was no problem as long as we were ready
to really engage discuss understand each
other and build that relationship
knowing each other that's just knowing
each other knowing them knowing their
difficulties and under at least using
what's available so that's what happened
with global fund the same thing we just
ask knock knock knock and was relatively
easier even this is what we want this is
what we planned this is how we want to
get there we need to build these others
in decisions we need to equip them the
government is committed we even
challenged the Global Fund by saying we
will build if we build one hunter with
you build one a center watching we don't
want to even sell you know sit wherever
we are and say give us they say we will
do part of our job with the resources
that we have and there are regions here
with me heads of regional health bureaus
States and they raised enough funding
from their own government too much each
and center built by
well fun so if global fund builds one
under center the government bill design
has a real center and they have
allocated funding for that and that kind
of partnership I think can be inculcated
if we just engage each other and listen
to each other and understand what could
be possible and use that possibility to
the maximum that was what happened but
even in peppering Global Fund people
thought that it's emergency so it's very
tight very strict no there were
opportunities they seem very small but
if they can be understood properly and
really positively and if can be if they
can be disgusted candidly I think were
enough to cover the whole valley system
and to support the whole health system
and that's what we have seen this before
in global fun and that's how we used it
and just addressing one of the questions
and then with that partnership may be
the one thing that's very clear was when
you say I want I want to do it I want to
get here I know how to get there at
least maybe you know part of it and you
may need a lot of support so although I
want you know hellas management
information system but I don't know how
to do it how to prepare the design then
this question brings a very good brings
a very good way of using technical
assistance what I'm saying is ok I need
a new or modern health management
information system but I don't want I
don't know it so what do what do i do I
ask for partners saying you know can you
give us technical assistance on HM is so
the technical assistance which is coming
is based on your need the hospital form
for instance when yell came based on
your need for Maskull finance supply
system based on our need but you know
many countries complain now but we don't
speak it candidly when ascertain partner
comes with a technical assistance ideas
and technical lesson and say you know I
want to do this I can help you on this
we don't say no we don't say no no I can
identify what areas of support I need in
terms of technique technical assistance
myself we don't say that and that's the
problem but when you know that plan the
most important element comes with it if
you know what you want to do although
you may not be able to do what you want
to design it and implement it you can
ask for technical assistance which is a
better or more effective technical
assistance because it's coming base it
on your need and it becomes
cost-effective also because that's what
you want and you can also owned it and
use it for the future so I think knowing
what you want is very clear then the
Condor I said it already but just to
mention that it's very important and i
would like to also provoke you by
raising one issue candidly I had a
speech in center for global development
on Monday and it was about country
ownership and I was describing country
ownership starting from planning to
resourcing budgeting one blonde one
business wants a report into
implementation to monitoring and
evaluation of the result framework
outcome and so on then this is a guy i
really respect i don't know if you know
him mr. edward Scott he is the chairman
and founder of Center for Global
Development and he is the founder of
dead something relief and so on he said
do you know I was asking for for
instance budget support countries
if countries could get budget support
which is very flexible based it on their
plan they can really use it flexibly and
properly so we're really tired of
thousands of transactions because we
plan thousand times to 1000 partners we
plan then you know monitoring and
evaluation with so many of them and we
report to all of them and this
transaction is really wrong very
confusing also so using budget support
it would be you know the best and he
said do you know some partners complain
about then I said what they think that
corruption is preventing them from doing
it because it could be true or wrong it
could be perception or reality in some
countries but that's what they are
saying do you really honestly discuss
this and candidly discuss this with the
partners I think that was very important
so I really thank ed important for that
comment and what I'm trying to say is
everybody agrees that budget support is
very important especially to use fundus
flexibly but when we discuss about that
together with corruption and
embezzlement and so on which could
happen in countries do we really discuss
it candidly so if you talk about
ownership I say we need to discuss
really candidly and do we have that
candor and are we ready really to under
to take it to that level if we can take
it to that level then I will take you
back to what I said earlier that regular
engagement and knowing each other and
discussing about issues really helps
because its regular negotiation regular
dialogue that you can build Kandra if
there is no like regular interaction
regular relationship dialogue it's very
difficult to inculcate
to cultivate candle because first time
you meet you cannot say you know people
would consider it even as arrogance if
you are like you know but through
dialogue through regular relationship
even what's making them uncomfortable as
what L what Scott said can be discussed
candidly so when we say Condor it
doesn't come just suddenly it can be
built and to be built there should be a
forum there should be a continuous
dialogue there should be a relationship
that we can develop then trust each
other then that's when Condor will also
be more effective more effective and to
use the funding which which was coming
the way we wanted it I think Condor and
that regular engagement had helped we
didn't start by saying let's speak
candidly we started the forum we started
to meet we started to have a common
platform we started to know each other I
started to understand their difficulties
they started to understand my
difficulties then that continuous
engagement started to bring really
candor and started to really understand
each other and that's why some of it we
try to really at least use the paper in
global fund of course what we thought
was seemingly small or a small impact
now is really big because we used that
flexibility that could be very small
special flexibility but that flexibility
to build the whole health system then I
will take you to another problem that we
have is the human resource development
in human resource development as you
know there is brain drain in Africa and
you can call any country in Africa and
whose doctors could be more in another
foreign country than in the country
itself for a cheaper for instance that
what they say
uh it could be right but I don't know it
could be right a number considering that
number of people I mean I met even in
Washington DC but we believe that in
order to address that problem we believe
that there is some problem in
understanding the real issue what I want
to say is we we consider the cause for
the problem is the brain drain itself
but in Ethiopia we believe it's not the
brain drain which is the cause of the
problem the shortage in in Ethiopia for
instance the problem is the mismatch
between supply and demand meaning in
Ethiopia there is a huge demand but we
are not supplying it or we're not
producing enough and because of that we
changed our strategy instead of blaming
the store poaching from us that our
doctors why not we just see inside you
know internal problem then the internal
problem was we were not producing enough
it took a really big country do you know
until three years ago the enrollment
rate was 250 doctors per year which is
very smart for 79 million population now
the last two years we have tried to grow
that and it's now 1400 so from 250 to
1400 and in three to four years we can
enroll up to 4,000 do you know Egypt
address it it's shortage of manpower
specially doctors by doing exactly same
thing do you know that they graduate
twelve thousand a year and us graduates
13,000 I I read so because of that
12,000 they don't need to take from
others they even
so I think that's one thing that we have
to correct by the way because from my
interaction with many colleagues they
complain about brain drain EO people are
poaching from us no but can we see
inside and see if there is another
problem could be major cause and it's
the supply and demand miss mine and by
other producing we can address that and
we have already done it for the low
level and mid-level health professionals
nurses we have more than enough now
hellas officers in just three to four
years by july 2011 we will graduate 5000
and more than a fifty percent of them
have already graduated by july 2011 the
5,000 total will be reached so you can
do that and we have health extension
workers 35,000 army nurses even better
than the wh 0 standard now by just over
producing or flooding strategy so we are
following now flooding and retention
strategy so you just produce as much as
possible in order to address the
shortage that's the best way to address
it then when you have shortages with
doctors what do you do what we're doing
is we're engaging them honestly
regularly also the few doctors that we
have we give them pre-deployment
training we train them on the strategies
of the country you know development
strategies including the health strategy
and we help them to understand the
country and we tell them candidly by the
way we started by holding their degree
not to leave the country when you have
shortage you don't have any option so we
hold their degree so that they will not
leave the country then they were very
sad when we did that then when we met we
honestly told them that it was wrong to
start without even discussing with them
we never even discussed with them so we
admitted that we asked excuse and then
we started this good
by candidly discussing about the
country's problems Fandral again here he
comes here reach the consensus on how we
can address the problem and then we
found a growing commitment in them few
years ago maybe we use to up deploy not
more than thirty percent of them seventy
percent we don't know where they were
going now we deploy more than ninety
percent of them they go ninety-five
percent they go where where they are
assigned to go and through candid
discussion on the problems reaching a
consensus on the problems and causes
root cause of the problem and also on
the solution and then to develop
commitment to help the country and it's
much better after we really started
candidly communicating with them so my
time is almost up so that one last thing
I would like to say is about best
practice and one problem we have
identified in best practices there could
be best practice but we don't learn from
each other there are best practices by
the way I can tell you when we design at
our new models information system
logistics hell is insurance for instance
we learn it from Wanda from Ghana from
Tanzania from Mexico from Nigeria from
Taiwan so our health insurance is now
cocktail of experiences from many
countries so one thing we have
identified which could be the same in
other countries is we don't look for
best practices actively and that we add
me what we admitted and try to really
look for best practices of course this
is a government reform we are doing it
as part of that this is not because this
is not what the health sector started
this is what the government started you
know we need to change we need to reform
our system and that's why we started
looking for
best practices and other system issues
for mystical finance from many countries
in our continent from Asia Latin America
we learn it a lot and this is prevention
especially the CDC type of model we
copied from CDC the whole motherboard of
course we cannot implement the whole
motherboard so we took a piece of what
you know something that looks like CDC
and we have already started implementing
and starting started even training fel
TP my master's program you know the
epidemic intelligence service service
officer ciso you can copy why do you
reinvent the wheel I think in in Africa
special in our continent and all modes
true for many developing countries or
mid-level mid-income they don't need to
invent they can't copy what they copy
could take them like would make a
difference of how many years maybe 50
years hundred years yeah it's true we
can copy that and then from that we can
maybe go into the cutting edge of
innovation but do we care about it now
so there are best practices elsewhere so
we don't learn from from each other and
the other problem with best practices we
start a very good one lab basic good
outcome best practice we don't scale it
up even after even in the country so
even in our own countries there are many
best practices but it's maybe in one
district in another district and we
don't really scale up that so that's
another problem and we need to identify
best practices from inside see how to
scale them up and even from outside and
how do we scale them up because without
scaling them up I don't think there will
be any impact so finally I would like to
thank all participants here and I would
like to end by saying you know whatever
we can learn from this I think
we have to take it and prepared also to
scale up but i hope what yell started
should grow you know to share best
practices because there are many best
practices as well and all of us can use
cocktail of best practices to make our
systems better so we are starting four
countries it's alphabetical order not
because i am favoring my own country if
you're pure ghana liberia and one that
lets start it to be honest we learned a
lot from you you don't know but we came
and learn it a lot from all of you and
we should do it consciously you know why
why not we have really a strong and
continuous forum like this one and try
to draw practices proactively and maybe
the next meeting of course organized by
air but we can do it in ghana and i
should say also that I'm proud of Ghana
at least that's our pride now the only
sir maybe a gift for that and learn from
what they are doing on the ground you
know a gift for their or the sock arena
so I would be happy together next time
and see what's what's going on but not
only how does insurance we learn that
many things from Ghana and many others
so let's really open our eyes and less
let's learn from each other there is a
lot of things to learn from each other
and ours is really something that has
been done by many countries you know
successfully implemented that we're
trying to make it ours and I would like
to use this opportunity to thank all
those who have supported us on this so
thank you so much again
I I think we have time for just a couple
questions maybe two or three questions
and dr. tedros he said you'd be willing
to of course okay so candor go ahead
Thank You honorable minister I've met
you so many times and have always been
fascinated by the way you come out the
way you you present things and the way
you encourage people remember that you
were with our lid minister Kishida yeah
and we'll really admire you what you've
said is true every part of it but I want
to look at it at the governmental level
and see whether even at that level we
shouldn't be coming together to look at
best practices and how governments can
be together to let us pick these things
up to work on in our country's human
resource is a problem you've there
you've been able to to manage it well
health insurance is good in Ghana the
four countries are learning a lot we
hold at the governmental level we have
various flora we hold you coerce
meetings if it is East African bloc if
it is a hey you how do we get ministers
to be together and say it love it oh
dear has done it in our next meeting
let's see the number of ministers that
will report on it because sometimes we
hope things this way we will have
good discussions it is that my Minister
made me to go for it that really going
back I'm putting it across and then
acceptable becomes a problem people like
you with vision and very well respected
I've lived at the cough mental level we
should have one two three areas let us
report on them let us see how we move
them and let us see how we move together
and that is what L want how do we get
our ministers at the various flora to
really accept that we have to achieve
results and not make take so many things
at a time but take them in in a
manageable manner so that we can achieve
results thank you jamar Elena oh sorry i
I'm seeing many faces similar so I told
them the same hole in the middle okay
okay please thank you very much for very
inspiring speech I would like to know
the budget support mentioned about your
support i think is a very good thing
after that how do you engage the
fattiness in monitoring what is
happening in ghana dfid done it I've put
virtual everything in the budget and
they realized that then they begin to
fold up the NIDA begin to fold up the
office then I went as I do you fold up
the office is there something more that
they can do to strengthen the system I
want to see how to know how you've
engage the partners in strengthening the
system on continuous basis apart from
maybe guess given a funding
yeah okay so I thank you so much i mean
the first one is a comment so I take it
as a comment and it can help in ensuring
accountability as you rightly said and
it can also help us focus on the most
important you know areas or limited
areas but really important areas to
focus on those and the high-level
relationship can also be built so I
think that's a very good comment but the
other thing I would like to say is it's
it's good if we have platforms you know
common forum and and so on and we should
really push for that and that's why I
suggested if we can you know let this
yeah grow and then discuss one tangible
the best practices by the way I was very
happy when I heard about live areas
experience on you know weekly reporting
on women library at Nellis yeah you know
we want to consider that because
maternal mortality is the most
challenging now of the older MDG goals
and it has to be treated accordingly
we're trying to focus on maternal
mortality and trying to really learn
from what others are doing and also not
really push it a lot but we are also
working on the performance based
financing of Rhonda of course at his
insurance and so on is gone so one thing
I would you know the common is good but
the country should leave
believe that should really believe in
best getting best practices proactively
itself meaning for innocence Rwanda
should continuously scan the environment
and get all any experience that it can
get the starting from neighboring
countries elsewhere then if you do that
when you get together when you use the
platform you will have even more
appetite because you you you you want to
do it whether there is a platform or not
so it should start from really being
interested on your own you know so I
encourage that I Charlie and then that
could lead us to the platform then when
we meet it's like honing or refining or
agreeing on some really best of best and
so on otherwise we should always realize
that the looking for best practices
should still remain the country's main
agenda and can its environment it should
start by the way from its own country
for enzymes in it a player there are
really best practices in one corner in
one village or in one district but which
is not identified so we should start
from identifying that using that to
scale and you know drawing best
practices from starting from neighbors
and and elsewhere so it should be the
responsibility of the country first and
it should really be actively searching
then the platform will help us in
Horning it but I take it as a comment
it's it's going it's it will help that
individual efforts and identifying even
better impact best practices then budget
support we have started by the way the
in Ethiopia also polled funding sign
Joint Finance agreement with for
bilaterals and for multilaterals and the
idea is you know they pull the funding
it's flexible
it's not earmarked and we are expected
to give them one plan and then during
the reporting also one report so it's
this is based on the idea of one plant
one budget one report so it's one plan
then one budget is they send their fund
their money to our account in one pool
then we only report one stall of them to
eight of them at least now and it's only
starting by the way and the first I
think they contributed around 200
million s dollars but this is a lot of
money by the way and they are now
abiding to that one plan one budget one
report at least this eight partners and
the engagement is during the planning
they want to know what we have planned
and not really to endorse it but they
can comment on that if we accept it we
take it if we don't they still don't
mind if we go ahead with our plan in
that plan what interests us more is
intelius them more is the result because
they want to see during the reporting
whether we have achieved what we say we
will achieve and they are giving money
so it's fine so they comment on the plan
that when we engage them and then they
give us their feedback many things we
accept because they have many experience
that people you know who can help
because we don't accept we say no
because maybe we have reason not to
accept that but we stood still go ahead
with the plan then when we report they
check the results so the engagement is
lighter so checking at the plant not to
endorse but to have a look what we have
planned and what we're going to achieve
then when we report then they see Feroli
whether you know we have achieved our
targets or not support from them even if
they close their offices to be honest i
don't know if i am going extreme here
but i wouldn't matter because as i said
earlier if you need technic
assistance you ask it specifically and a
technical assistance can come for
exactly what you wanted to need
assistance for not just regular support
but very targeted so the technical
assistance could be for six months three
months or one year or two years it will
be based on your need so it doesn't
matter whether they have the office your
their office in the country or not as
long as there is a mechanism to see the
plan then a mechanism to transfer the
funding then a mechanism to get the
report and comment on the report because
that's the most important one when you
need technical assistance it will
entirely be up to you you know of course
to build your capacity you need
technical assistance then it has to be
tailored based on your need so these are
the two I think huh vodka yeah okay so
thank you very very much one small thank
you for having me and I wish you all the
best and let's continue having best
practices that can and learning from
that exactly um address i would like to
give you this on behalf of yale which
you've spoken so highly of and ghl I as
well and you seems as if you've given us
our agenda okay decade thank you so much